in keeping with what we've been going
through our recent topic of real
functions and we spoke super very close
to introducing calculus I'm gonna give
you some new ideas which required new
language and they're going to build on
some of the tension we've just just
recently a look at now continuity like
when something is continuous okay this
is not that we than idea in fact like
most of what we've been doing so far in
real functions straight lines parabolas
logs blah blah blah blah blah they are
all what we would call continuous right
you can you can draw these things
without picking up your pen okay you
don't have to you know stop pick up in
draw again if I the first time we looked
at a graph that wasn't continuous was
that's with a pay one kind of munch it
piecemeal functions very good right like
it's it's it's here it's here and then
and so on
yes ah very good
okay now piecemeal functions as you've
noticed are not the only kinds of
functions that have well that are not
continuous okay and y equals 1 over X is
a classy damn it's like pretty much the
first one that you like where you're
like oh it exists all these places but
this kind of a big gaping hole now when
we say big gaping hole like it looks big
but actually the hot the hole is
infinitesimally small infinitesimally
small all it is is the y axis right it
exists everywhere else so you know it's
in fact you know the limit the limit as
X approaches 0 is infinity right you can
get you can put in any value like so
long it's it's just a smidgen above zero
ok so this idea of continuity let me
give you an informal definition of
if simply our function is continuous
function is continuous and I'm going to
I'm going to qualify a little bit
because I just say when I give you a
formal definition it's gonna need some
notation like kind of fee but we need
this phrase I'm about to give you a
function is continuous
now what I'm implying is we're thinking
about whether it's continues at
particular points on the graph okay so
for instance I might say you know x
equals 1 or x equals 2 or I might say at
x equals 0 right
is the function continuous or not so
function is continuous at a point if the
graph can be drawn and if you can go
through that point that point without
lifting your pen or pencil I should say
if you can do it in one fell swoop it's
continuous and that's a fairly standard
not not crazy idea okay so for instance
whatever X is continuous at x equals 1
like I can I can keep dry enough to pick
up it's continuous 2x equals 2 & 3 & 4 &
everywhere except for x equals 0 right
so this is this property of continuity
right it's about whether I can pass
through them and no breaks occur now let
me give you a formal method and our
language of limits is really what we
kind of really developed it so we could
say this okay a function is continuous
it starts the same way
now so that I can actually put some
notation here that makes sense I'm going
to name the point I'm gonna call it a
and x equals a he comes to the notation
you ready think about what it is as I
write it because hopefully our
understanding of limits now is
sophisticated enough that when I put
this down it's just gonna make sense
there we go
this there we go yeah this is kind of
like death by death by symbols okay but
hopefully as you start to process it
okay I think I see where this is getting
yet right this form edition definition
is follow powerful than this one
what is it saying with regards to a
function right I can put values in and I
can also that's pretty values in and I
can also see what happens as I put
values that are closer and closer and
closer to a particular spot even if I
can't get to that's one I can do that
right so what does this mean this means
as X gets closer and closer closer to a
from from below from below or in terms
of X that would mean from the left okay
I should get towards something right
that should be equal to what I'm
approaching if I come from the opposite
direction from the right okay this one's
coming from the left in fact you might
even like to wrong because it's negative
it seems to the Eichner down but it
really just means from the left in the
example that I just gave you all
approaching to x equals one you'd have
0.98 0.99 and 0.999 none of those values
are negative they're coming from the
negative direction that limit should be
equal to the same thing that you get
from the right and lastly both of those
limits as you're getting closer and
closer closer they should think what
you're actually equal to when you put in
the value right this is the function
okay all these three things must be
equal otherwise your function is not
continuous there is a break-even okay
yes that's right
that's exactly right so let's let's give
it as a test case in fact I have purple
eyes heaps of problems so as an example
right let's on let's let f of X equal 1
X because let's all get this down
together right if we are considering a
point like we will consider it a point
of continuity first right let's consider
the example I was given before is X
equal right so what I'm looking for is
these three pieces and they all must be
equal right I have to converge so I have
to the way I test this if I say well
what's the limit as X approaches 1 from
the negatives from the bottom right from
left
I should say that right what is it
approaching like if I say 1 over is 0.9
and 1 over 0.99 and get closer and
closer and closer and the answer is I'm
approaching 1 ok I am approaching I
think about what happens as I go from
the opposite direction X + 1 over 1.01
or 1.001 or 1.0 or however many you want
to put there it's also approaching 1
lastly all after test is f of 1 right
which is just 1 over 1 which sure enough
is 1 these are all equal right therefore
f of X 1 over X is continuous at what
does that make sense
just testing out that there were leave
ah so when I do this right if I now
consider so so my concluded from this is
continuity at x equals one right yep
well I mean it does matter in that it
must approach from both directions the
same value it must approach okay and
we'll look at some counter examples well
we're about to look at counties April
the second right as I approach zero
right let's see what happens from the
left the limit as X approaches 0 from
the negative side okay so in this case I
am actually having like minus point 1
and minus point 0 1 and minus point zero
zero one I've get closer close to 0 from
this side
what's it approaching sorry
yeah it's approaching negative infinity
is it not right think back to our formal
definition of what does it mean for like
what is the limit and the answer is it's
whatever value I can get arbitrarily
close to just by supplying some kind of
X so you're like how about a million so
I should say negative right
can you get close to negative million
yeah you're just to pick a really small
X how about negative like a googol yeah
you just pick a smaller X you can get as
far as you want there for negative
infinity if you look at the other side
exactly the same thing is happening but
in Reverse of course ok so we've already
we've already ruled out continuity in
this interval okay
because these two things aren't the same
so I don't even need to get to this next
point right which of course is undefined
but